citizens of the reject Nation it is time
once again for some
b99 abiding by the law and by the laws
of this channel if you can go ahead and
leave a like subscribe to the video and
be sure to come and check us out over at
patreon.com real rejects sync up with
your own copy of Brooklyn Nine-Nine and
all the other shows we got going over
there it's a good time let's just hop
into it
we talked in the original room for a
second there's a question I gotta ask
you I'm so relieved I thought maybe he
was going to ask one of Amy's brothers
or Sarge hey man come on Charles
so I know this is a lot to ask no it's
not I want to do it you want to cover my
shift this weekend so I can go to the
White Plains mall and meet Daryl
strawberry at the opening of a cell
phone store
Psych exactly what I was hoping you'd
ask great you sure it's okay
very happy about it
[Music]
[Applause]
no what do you say Bud will you be my BM
in your face Terry what I'm holding the
sparkler for you I helped organize a lot
of this well you can stick that sparkle
off your butt I'm the best man
all right that got me how
I really thought he was just gonna ask
him to cover his shift there was a
different joke coming I am a writer's
dream
[Music]
[Laughter]
Daniel valdano valdano is going to
actually leave his house to go to a high
stakes poker game this Friday this watch
to him and he's bugged yes it's bugged
good guess captain
how are your poker skills hi good is
that good all right so good perhaps I
should see for myself oh do you play I
am I I wanted to take you two to come up
with that that was a two dare okay well
hand me some files
bro
you couldn't sit all day if you tried
what both cheeks on the cushion at all
times bathroom breaks two and a half
minutes every three hours but you gotta
roll the chair fully into the stall okay
let's go
everyone else was like oh they're the
knee in the friar and it was so food out
of this I found a knee in the fryer
exactly you get it well now you have to
go pick it up you can't get a good deal
from those things I win again but I can
play yes but you have a rather
unfortunate tell your right breast
my cards are terrible
Eugene no I don't gamble anymore a few
years back I had a minor addiction
specifically involving the ponies I'd
like to bet twenty thousand dollars
[Music]
I could be outside in the surveillance
van telling Peralta what to do addiction
is nothing to fool around with I need to
create a hams once yeah and look at you
now you're like a super jacked He-Man
guy it's settled we'll go with a
captain's plan I mean you must have to
eat a lot to maintain let's have glasses
that can see
I'm coming in under the gun and I've got
15K behind questions on you
mmm tasty razor 500. raise a five hundo
I'm just talking to myself I'm used to
playing online so it's not weird
backstory a plus I'm all in and now they
all fold like so much recently dried
linen I can't quite an idiot two players
oh no he won not you you're out of chips
oh well that sucks head back to my mom's
basement I'm a virgin
I haven't placed a bet or touched the
card I'm fine technically that is true
trust me the math is in our favor all
right
no place to do it like the men's
bathroom to leave from here to go do
what we were talking about nine hours
and 55 minutes is it I feel like I just
sat down I have no feeling down here
whatsoever yes
that's mine come get it
[Music]
you'll never catch me
come on Rosa
the cards are coming and there she is I
won you won one again that's our
strength and again again damn for all to
see hot damn hot damn
I'm sick of playing with little widdle
babies is there a table for people who
wear big boy pants private game on
Friday I think you might like
much obliged
Boogie can we talk about the murder
truck we just purchased
oh what is Frozen all night sight gag
it's just what if word gets out that our
food truck was the site of a double
homicide what if Ford gets out it's in
the hour story section of the menu we're
calling it murder truck we are yeah
once you see our truck you'll feel a lot
better no no no no no my truck my
beautiful truck someone ripped her apart
please tell me you got insurance that
coverage starts tomorrow oh that's
terrible technically I'm the one wearing
the watch so that would make you cue at
best Terry Q yeah way to roll with it
come on let's still hold for prep for
tonight I gotta say I was wrong about
him he had no problem walking away last
night ugh oh no honey sweet with salt
Sergeant come back to me what you don't
want to brought up ham that was you yes
yes
raise it a grand
and why are you watching this children's
beauty pageants for fun obviously Jalen
don't drop the Baton no I had so much
writing on you ugh
Holden's been in his office gambling for
hours our only choice is to cut off his
internet you just have to pull this go
ah wrong Wire yeah we'll uh we'll fix
that later just pull the wires
what the hell what are you doing trying
to pick up a Wi-Fi signal from across
the street don't you think you have a
bit of a problem here sir I'm in
complete control now Terry come over
here and dangle me off the edge of this
building
[Laughter]
I want to see that relapsing is nothing
to be ashamed of a couple years ago on
my birthday I treated myself to one
piece of pizza I woke up the next
morning in a sabaro on the Jersey
Turnpike oh no
what's happening here I'm not weak like
you are I can stop whenever I want
didn't stop I don't want now I don't
want we'll call your husband
I've lost control and I'm not going
anywhere near gambling again so I'm
sorry Terry you went to Jersey for pizza
I had a problem
[Laughter]
[Music]
when I walk up to the hot dog stand out
front and get a fresh wiener oh man
why'd you say that no I want one you
should all go get one
the only thing holding us back is
society
[Laughter]
ah that does look fun in the elevator
[Music]
no oh
it was my time
very very Zen I know who robbed us the
cartel who did the taco truck murders
ripped apart the truck because there was
heroin still inside it we found opioid
traces behind the fridge I had forensic
scour the truck for DNA nice do you know
what this means the truck becomes a
crime scene again yes it's been
impounded we get our money back great oh
you can invest it in something you
actually believe in instead of my balls
I have 50 pounds of meat I have to
return before it goes rotten like my
dreams
I'm about to crap the bed evening
gentlemen ready for some poker that's
why we're here good one stranger I'll
take 150.
hot damn
Four Queens oh oh my god oh jeez
what happened I wanted to download
anymore for Kevin sir you are spiraling
you lied straight to our faces well
that's on you if you could spot my tail
haha
wow listen to you talking all smooth but
you can't fool us sir you're addicted to
math Robert Palmer come on sorry let's
go
might as well face it you're addicted to
math so you're a cop
there was a pooper no
pooper
so I understand you're a cop he's trying
to bring me down let me take a little
Drive
wowie this is terrible sir please just
come back okay Terry and I will keep you
company we'll go to a museum one of the
boring ones with no dinosaurs forget
it hold on there come on yeah
yeah I should have tried them earlier I
lost track of the fact that this whole
thing was supposed to be about your food
but I have some conditions one it cannot
be a crime Scene
Three you have to keep dreaming up
amazing things to cook you're so good
Boyle
yeah
I ate too many meatballs oh
throw it up I'm a captain in the NYPD
yeah I lost all your money in AC and
then drown yourself in the ocean
[Applause]
Keep Your Hands on the Wheel
s hey there Captain Hull we just saved
your big old butt hello Dan Daniel
valdano guess what you're a dick
you traced your phone and tracked down
the limo how did you even know I was in
trouble when you're lying you use
contractions lots of them I've lost
control I'm taking myself off the cake I
shouldn't have answered you shouldn't
have answered
it shouldn't have finally tipped me off
I've never heard you use a double
contraction before
he knows what a contraction is
I was at rock bottom
I feel so embarrassed I understand I've
been there I once ate a box of uncooked
rice in a movie theater wow
I was overwhelmed by my addiction and
you were there for me we do anything for
you I need to admit one more thing of
course anything when I made you tell
that table that you were living in your
mother's basement it wasn't for the case
I was just messing with you
but the joke's on you my mother has a
fantastic basement title your sex tape
too soon all right let's go
standing down
care of herself someone 's sitting down
on the job hey hey sitting down the job
is damned hard work and those
[Laughter]
for your hearts
that's funny
Ah that's great
that was great take it away John I was a
delightful episode every plot line I
enjoyed
immensely and uh yeah I really liked
this Pro like the the whole gambling
story did not unfold the exact way I
expected it to but it still brought a
lot of good character stuff to light a
lot of good fun and hijinks and it took
me back to the olden days where we went
through that sort of uh you know
big old Poker Face I remember
pokerstars.com was a big thing we were
always playing and then uh you know even
the times were like you know our old
improv crew get together for poker night
or things like that so just got me
thinking of all the good times I have
had whilst gambling
for money uh so yeah I appreciated that
I really enjoyed the unexpected
camaraderie that arose from the orosa
storyline as well as uh you know all the
exploits and Misadventures of Amy and
Boyle uh yeah I don't want to say too
much what you think what'd you think
you don't want to say too much but you
you cover it all
well I only just addressed like I just
named everything that happened I didn't
unpack the ball I didn't like assess
them or pick out the major details
themes and other bits of richness to be
extracted
they simply laid the structure down
all right I'll give it to you
I'll give it to you
well done John
let it be known this day
oh I should talk now
I mean you don't have to we could just
sit here
I would hate that
I
love Rosa
I've been attracted to her since day one
oh
and I'll do anything to obtain her
I want Stephanie Beatrice not the
actress I want her to stay in character
yeah yeah
I don't care for her real life
personality soft pudding
I've never seen an interview with her
I've seen like a clip and I went nope
you want to be like Rosa yes
uh there's something so funny to me
about I think it was just because Rosa
is usually in the
no pun intended
she's usually in the chair
seated in a position
to solely judge yes other people and
especially Hitchcock and soul who are
two people
that you would a thousand percent judge
who pretty much exists in this show to
be eye rolled at
and for her to be the one
the least likely candidate yet the one
that makes the most sense to be
participating in this game due to the
nature of competition
just really tickled me to my core
because of the fact that yeah it's just
such such a dichotomy
this duality of them
these characters
to be able to interact like that and
just the commitment to such a childlike
game I like Slackers I like slacker
comedies I don't care for Slackers in
real life I could like slacker comedies
and I like uh you know these office
workspace environments where they get
bogged down with meaningless tasks
because they find ways to entertain
themselves and I like what it escalated
into and even by the time
Hitchcock stood I was like oh hey
I like the way it was done it was so
so spurred the moment you don't even see
it coming as an audience member you
don't you dumb Boyle's best man now he
is
Boyle's best man who saw that coming and
I'm like Johnny's enthusiastic about it
I was very exciting actually excited
about it I was thrilled to be your best
man negative I just didn't want to screw
it up you did it near the best part of
the wedding even more than the ideas
thanks
it's really all about me that weekend as
much as John week this is my time to
shine with all the guests it was a great
day
so exhausting yeah especially in the
cold uh yeah that was fun
where's this boil an Amy restaurant come
from yeah I I have no idea and I was
like this is a significant investment
where do you just have the money as cops
for for this but uh you know
you invest in index funds that grow over
time over the course of 10 years
savings bonds stocks Roth IRAs there's a
lot of ways they could have accumulated
that money over the years John they're
probably in their 40s and Amy and Boyle
are both the kinds of characters who
would be uh responsible enough and with
enough foresight to make such decisions
so that really that definitely tracks
you put a little bit of thought into
that before he had asked such a
judgmental question of course that's my
mistake that's just me showing my
inability to process economics properly
but yeah as a story Point alone bit
random but I thought it was fun
and then yeah the gambling story I wish
we saw more poker I love poker that's
why I didn't beat Red Dead 2.
so you just kept playing poker playing
poker it's a real thing that happened
not bad have you played Red Dead
Redemption I have not well in Red Dead
Redemption it's what they call an open
world video game John and sometimes
there are these side missions that
really cause a player like me to have
anxiety because I feel it distracts from
getting on with the journey and there's
sections in the game where you can go
sit down with a couple of other Cowboys
and play some poker and then before you
know it you've been playing poker for
three hours and haven't completed One
mission
because you just want to get good at me
and then poker and you feel like it's
honing in on your skills sure not even
gambling real money you're gambling with
game money
and what do you what do you what do you
hit you just press buttons to to fold or
not fold or
it's a video game so yes that is how it
works like what are the controls for
this
how fun and engaging could that I guess
it must be fun and engage I've just
never I've never rerouted the mechanics
no different than like online poker yeah
you're not playing on a mobile yeah you
have Red Dead online where you can play
those sense yeah that's fair that's fair
I'm just having trouble mapping it out
over the game controller but yeah it's
got to be a few simple case yeah there's
a fold call or
not a lot it's not a lot there's enough
button interesting so it has all the
different things you can do in real
poker so you know maybe before asking
it's a heinous questions you just
consider the mathematics of how many
options you get when you're sitting at a
poker table and if that coincides with
how many buttons there are on a
PlayStation controller this is this is
Red Dead Redemption 2 is that available
on PS3 I can go get a copy God no it's
not all right the design for the PS4
then I won't be playing oh I could get a
cheap PS3 PS4 then that's that's my plan
PS4s have to cost like 10 bucks now so
now I'll swoop in for the previous Next
Generation
never met someone with a gambling
addiction
no I don't know if I have you there
I I remember man I've only played cards
for real at like a casino once or twice
and it's just
it's not going well
I'm not good at Blackjack oh okay
I'm always like I'm an 18.
that was my next one might be three
always shoot for three that's right
that's good but hey on that one where
you hit it
some of that back
I think I've uh I've played blackjack
and like to hold him probably at an
actual poker table
I'm gonna Texas Hold'em five car drop
whatever I'm good at that if I have like
on my phone if I pull up
like what the hands are that you can get
because I often don't recall even right
now in this moment I'm like I don't know
what's higher what beats what yeah is it
straight or a flush but like I I like
right out of this momentum I don't know
so if I have it in front of me
I can look I can take the time to assess
like what someone else might have yeah
and determinant because oftentimes if I
don't have something in front of me I'm
just focused on what I have and not
really considering unless it's like
really obvious what's out there um
anyway guys go gamble yes go do it
that's the message YouTube likes when
you tell audiences to do that sit down
it's apparently a really good thing you
want to encourage people to do eat some
meatballs take a seat and yeah just
spend the rest of the day betting your
your life away yeah
I'd love to play poker again I love
poker dude have a poker night
you don't have the space John
fair fair enough can't make it happen no
it's impossible I don't have space no
space
do it around the fire pit
I think I'll make it happen yeah and
then we all play for real money and
watch
friendships and
big money alrighty guys well you be safe
take care fall in love
and uh have a baby yes now now